so why am i bringing all this up a lot
of you probably don't care about hip-hop
nor do you care about this topic but i
want to bring this up to you because
this is important in regards to business
and friends and managing something okay
it's
very difficult so i'm going to give you
the cliff notes so joe budden
he's a music artist part of
slaughterhouse rapper et cetera et
cetera he starts a podcast
two friends end up joining that's rory
and maul they start working together on
the podcast co-hosts have some great
moments
it's a popular podcast now they have a
profit sharing deal means
based off the profits each prism gets a
percentage joe gets the lion's share
because he's a bigger name they also get
a percentage each okay
the problem comes into the fact that
based off the contracts they had written
they wanted to be able to see the books
they wanted to see the financials so
they could understand
how much of the profits that they're
actually getting right because you don't
know
how much you're supposed to get unless
you could see all the money do you
understand
but joe wouldn't show them that so he's
like well how do you know my percentage
or how can i confirm my percentage
if you won't show me the books very
basic stuff if you're an employee
you work somewhere it's an hourly thing
you are allowed to ask your manager how
many hours did i work this week to
calculate your pay
all right it's not some arbitrary number
right as more money comes in more
questions get
asked eventually they come to a head he
doesn't like ask him so many questions
so he removes them from the podcast
he has what i believe is one of the most
unprofessional firings ever he gets on
air and he says a whole bunch of stuff
you guys are fired on a live podcast of
people you call friends
super messy that's why they say family
business and friends they don't mix and
oftentimes
it's true but i think it's also true
because of how people approach it
the mindset the values right
and also the ethics involved joe feels
like because he does more of the work
he doesn't have to answer to his
partners maybe there's something more
shady maybe he's stealing money behind
these things i can't say for sure i'm
not going to
say that but it is kind of shady that
people who have the right to have access
to the books
you don't give it to them you tell them
there's accounting errors and all this
other stuff
it will make people feel uneasy if you
feel like there's nothing to hide and
they should be able to see what's going
on behind closed doors
show it to them it is their right when
you don't of course people are going to
assume something shady is happening
because you're not giving them access to
something that they should have access
and this comes the ethics aspect these
are your partners and when you don't
treat them as such of course they're
going to feel offended of course they're
going to feel devalued
you're treating them like employees when
that's not what they are and you
talk to them like they are employees
that's not how you run
it shows poor leadership you getting in
front of the whole world and firing
even if you don't want to work with them
why would you broadcast that to
everybody
right it's messy all around
and joe has a history of this so this is
where rory and maul's
accountability come joe has a history of
this plenty of people warned them that
this guy is not somewhere to be worked
with
but they were like now we're friends joe
would never joe did and there has to be
some accountability from you not
learning from history
there has to be some kind of community
from you ignoring all the signs when he
wouldn't show you the books for multiple
years
it wouldn't be transparent with you and
it was disrespectful on air like
there has to be some level of like has
he changed or is this getting worse and
worse
why didn't you guys do anything
beforehand now eventually you guys did
whatever it is
but also understand that's where your
accountability comes into place
and the third and last thing i'm gonna
say is this if you're gonna do
business with friends and family make
damn
sure that you're doing it
more than just oh that's my [ __ ] you
have to make sure that they have the
character to run a business with you
and you also have to write [ __ ] down
right sit down write [ __ ] down but the
biggest thing i'm gonna say is
you have to make sure that both of you
agree
which one takes priority your friendship
or the business so that's pretty much
what i'm gonna say
i've been around foreign business and
family business
bro let me tell you this it's rough when
we say that money corrupts when we say
that money talks and all that [ __ ] and
when we talk about that friends
family it don't matter it don't matter
when that greed come in
that greed that jealousy all of that
i spare the details but i've seen that
i've seen that yeah too many times
unfortunately you think you're going to
be acquainted with a friend and then
you're going to be like yo that's my
homie for life
hold me for life and then you see dirty
tricks behind the back of [ __ ]
great people not wanting to open books
people claiming money that is not theirs
family and through the history of time
you've seen this [ __ ] happening
what makes you think what makes you
think that this is not going to happen
to you
that you immune to all of this that your
casper to friendly goes to this
see right through you when money and big
money comes in that's why you got to do
business with people that have the same
goal as you but it's hard sometimes you
won't know
until you find yourself in that position
it's crazy people are still surprised
when we say that we're not friends
that's for a reason we're not we're not
trying to clout chase or we're not
trying to be like
uh this and that and that my guard was
like yo but you
didn't develop a friendship no we
developed money
we definitely developed camaraderie we
definitely developed
mutual respect for the other person is i
think the thing comes into play where
at the end of the day the business
always comes first without a doubt
it's not even done and for me if i have
to approach our relationship so
differently than all my other
friendships i can't
use the same word for you dig what i'm
saying it's like
i gotta talk to you on some business
[ __ ] and it has to be straight to the
point with zero feelings and
consideration involved
it has to be about the business and so
i'm happy about it because i think we've
seen this thing flourish and we've seen
it done pretty smoothly
there was a rocky period but it was more
so about like our personalities gelling
in a work sense more than anything
on a personal level me and you being
friends outside this would be so easy
because
values align in the right places right
but on a work level it's a different
thing and when that takes precedent
everything else is on the back i would
never
think of running a business with my wife
or something like that
i'll be honest with you i would be so
hard for me because then you would take
all your problems home
and your business issues into the
bedroom into everything that
disagreement like
me and you have disagreements and
sometimes we need to just breathe on it
but [ __ ] you live together
yeah do you think what i'm saying yeah
you can't [ __ ] go out and be like
i want to go back home and talk [ __ ] to
my wife yo you know what this
[ __ ] said yeah
this [ __ ] said to me but now the
[ __ ] is my wife
exactly if it's the same thing with me
you go back is the same
if if i was in a relationship with my
pillow and we had a business together
who am i going to talk to other than my
pillow you know what i'm saying like you
got your wife i got my pillow
yeah yeah lonely
he is so lonely he's not lonely don't
the girls don't slide into the end
we're not going to read you yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah but um it's sad
it's so sad when you see just a great
dynamic between people and you think how
did it go so sour they were so awesome
together
but y'all don't see what happens behind
their currents and you don't see how
hard it is for people to
stop thinking logically because they're
like this person is my friend it's like
[ __ ] it's business
i go to a fortune 500 company they don't
talk like you do they say
give me the financials or my lawyer
comes for you why because they
understand
it's a weird world when it comes to
money so be very careful when you
involve your friends
contracts are necessary do not skimp out
and honor them
and also get that hierarchy get that
hierarchy
know who you're getting in business with
and understand what you value in there
because rory when you listen to their
explanation of what happened on the joe
button podcast and
how things went behind you could tell he
valued the friendship a lot more than he
did
the business relationship and doing that
ruined both
i would argue if he was more stern about
business he might have been able to
preserve both but now look at it
right so that's just something you've
seen stories of this happening right
go ahead tell them it's in my family
okay i've seen it in my family so i'm
not gonna have a spare
i'm gonna spare the details but
sometimes when your money gets
money gets in the way of things and they
can get in the way of family sometimes
family i'm not talking about friends
and it's been going on through ages and
you think you're gonna be an exception
fine cool good good luck yeah so you
know i just don't want to see any more
people fall out i don't want to see
groups fall out i want to see duels and
you know if you're not business savvy go
get some information from someone who is
you know get counsel people you can talk
to be like is this normal is this not
and then talk to the person you're in
business with
and have candid conversations do not sit
on disagreements
okay because it's not that very
different than a real relationship talk
to each other if you guys got problems
don't let that [ __ ] fester
don't let passive aggressiveness fester
do not let
unresolved issues stick around because
eventually you blow up on something far
larger than what it needs to be
have constant confrontation check in
with each other hey is everything good
can i can i see some of the financials
yeah give it transparency is going to be
so good
and as far as joe budden goes super
disappointing
as somebody who talks about not wanting
to be uh
you know [ __ ] the industry i'm gonna do
it myself till you pull an industry move
and say i got my contracts on you never
starting another podcast
super trash super trash okay
that's super garbage all right
you getting on on this public platform
and being messy in front of everyone
super trash whether it's your friends or
your businesses it's so unprofessional
such an indication
of poor leadership i can't tell you how
distasteful it is
i don't care what happens between me and
preach you will never see me get online
here
and start to denigrate the man
regardless that [ __ ] stays between us
and if we gotta have a huge falling out
it's gonna be
silence and y'all know no it's not gonna
be fun
but that's how i want to keep it all
right i'm not gonna be messy
that's not gonna be your business it's
not it's not gonna be none of your
business if we need to fight we're
fighting but
i'm not gonna put the whole business out
there what happened well
what was good was good and it's not
happening no more i don't
it's crazy it's like people they work
with people some people
people they work with they consider him
too much of a friend
and fans are now because they're so
close and sometimes they have a
relationship with fans
fans are become friends as well yeah
and now they're dashing out the whole
thing to fans fans don't need to know
half the [ __ ] you're putting out there
have the [ __ ] but you're putting it out
there
it's like ugh yeah nah man i don't like
it either and as far as his apology goes
i'm sorry that i hurt someone close to
me that's an apology
it's like saying i made amends i'm not
going to hurt you anymore you didn't
make amends you know what i'm saying
yeah that's what you're saying i guess
that's the only thing it's like this if
i bring a grievance to you
you don't address the grievance and
you're like no
i'm sorry i hurt somebody i left that's
not an apology
yeah am i crazy i'm sorry i hurt someone
i love
and the person that you love would be
the person you're talking to
that you hurt so that's yeah this is an
apology i'm sorry i hurt you
it's an apology it's you being sorry you
got hurt
sorry i hurt you i'm sorry about i
possibly for what i did
is one thing and the other thing is i'm
sorry for how you feel
it's another thing which knocking on if
you're going into that
i understand the difference and i
understand how someone can feel like
yeah you're not really it's not really
one of them has less accountability you
understand what i'm saying
it's not even about less accountability
there's no accountability
it an apology means nothing
if you're not acknowledging what you did
wrong do you dig what i'm saying
yeah because what does an apology mean
in the circumstance if you didn't
acknowledge what you did to me
or if you haven't even acknowledged like
that you have a problem so basically the
reason why he fired him was for what
he just decided to fire them he fired
them because he felt like
listen i'm gonna be honest with you he's
not very clear as to why he fired them
what is very clear is that he was they
weren't transparent they were asking
questions and he wouldn't answer
and he got sick of their questions if
you don't address that none of this
other stuff about apologies means
anything
it wouldn't mean anything to me and it
won't mean anything to them and also
let's also be clear
he hasn't apologized to both them only
one of them so it's not like he's
addressed the grievances
he's like that's my real [ __ ] so i'm
apologizing because i [ __ ] with him
you're not addressing what's wrong you
know what i'm saying absolutely people
came to me with this story i'd be like
it'd be interesting to see your point of
view
since you have a show with uh
abba and i was like this is not the same
thing
am i crazy yeah for thinking it's not
the same thing it's like
they were side pieces you know i mean
they were
you see in the title of the show abba
and preach and how abba is written the
same
your height and the same fun as preach
abba and preach the same thing this was
like
it really felt like it really had vibes
of if this show was around
joe i mean he felt like he was the main
drum to be fair he really is
and he was on the ip the ip belongs to
him so i'm not mad at him for the name
the thing is if they're your partners
they may not be equal partners
but if they are partners they have
certain rights that you have to respect
considering the investment
that they've put in it's like me and you
may not put in the same amount of work
into this
but because your contribution is so
large you have a right to see all the
financials
you have a right to have access to the
whole page you have a right to have
access to all the stuff behind the
scenes
because of the fact that you are heavily
invested it's like if you're working on
a board
of a company you get access to a lot
you get access to most of it maybe one
if you're a holder
you might maybe you don't have all the
shares but you see the finances now
things are affected
you're not the biggest shareholder
you're probably not the majority
shareholder but your shareholder
you're gonna have you're gonna be part
of the reunions and stuff like that
so yeah definitely when they're gonna
say when the shareholders say
crack the books open you don't have to
crack the books open because they want
to see
where they put their money yep and every
now and there there's a bulletin
that is provided to the shareholders and
they're shareholders
and they have a right to know that's
like the really important thing because
they have a right
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
hold on
you